les lycéens ont droit eux aussi à leur
lot de changements pour la rentrée la
semaine dernière le conseil régional
d'île de france a présenté les
nouveautés prévues pour cette année
au programme un ensemble de mesures sur
la sécurité dans les établissements la
lutte contre le décrochage scolaire et
la radicalisation c'est camille lambert
qui nous en dit plus avec la menace
terroriste cette rentrée 2016 ne sera
pas comme les autres pour les 500 mille
lycéens d'île de france le 30 août le
conseil régional a annoncé les
évolutions attendues dans les lycées
budget prévu pour ces changements plus
de 660 millions d'euros 10 millions
seront consacrés à sécuriser les
bâtiments un montant doublé par rapport
à 2015 ça va nous permettre de réaliser
dans 130 clichés des opérations de
sécurisation alors scellé clôture à
l'entrée c'est de la vidéoprotection
s'est dessiné des signaux d'alarmé
etc etc ça correspond à des demandes des
lycées pour faire face évidemment aux
risques auxquels ils sont soumis
nouveauté cette année l'expérimentation
d'un budget d'autonomie pour douze
lycées publics franciliens
une enveloppe de 780 mille euros est
mise en place dans les yvelines deux
établissements testeront ce dispositif
objectif donner plus de souplesse si
permettre aux équipes éducatives de
faire vraiment leur choix pour leur
lycée ils ont besoin de languirand
supplémentaire ils ont besoin de cours
de soutien supplémentaires ils veulent
faire une spécialité sur le numérique
ils veulent faire une spécialité
internationale ils peuvent choisir la
région entend aussi lutter contre la
radicalisation en organisant des
conférences animées par des témoins du
terrorisme de parents de victimes de
mohamed merah ont accepté de participer
différentes actions culturelles seront
programmés pour favoriser l'ouverture
d'esprit on veut faire entrer plus de
cultures les plus d'éducation artistique
dans les lycées d'île de france parce
que je crois que la culture c'est la
réponse à la barbarie et c'est aussi un
outil extraordinairement fort de
cohésion nationale depuis 2013 le nombre
de jeunes en décrochage scolaire stagne
aux alentours de 30 mille l'île de
france souhaite renforcer les actions de
prévention
valérie pécresse prévoit d'organiser des
assises du décrochage scolaire avec le
corps enseignant et des associations
les discussions
on devrait se tenir fin septembre